[Music]
hello mr. Knight my question is that
even though it would never happen if you
could go back in time to observe any
prehistoric animal or animals which
would it be for me it would be the giant
arthropods of the Carboniferous well
Christian this is a fabulous
hypothetical question but let's say we
didn't go prehistoric let's see we went
historic the animal that I would like to
see is the Steller's sea cow this is a
marine mammal apparently very much like
a manatee but lived in saltwater in the
Bering Sea and then off Alaska or
Siberia and this thing was driven to
extinction not too long ago in the 1700s
and I could imagine an extraordinary
technology that would take the bones of
one of these creatures which are in
certain collections and somehow
reproduce effectively enough the DNA of
that animal and have him or her come
back and start over again because that
animal very recently was in the
ecosystem up there they say up there in
Alaska is Siberia the barents sea
perhaps that it would be it might be a
great thing to actually reintroduce it
to the ecosystem and it would be a
spectacular deal as far as going way
back in time what cells and movies giant
ancient dinosaurs I give you though the
the huge millipedes that you were
talking about Christian now that's cool
but that it's not first on my list well
see how it goes that's the cool question
[Music]